tu es Harvey peu importe les mensonges que tu
te dis tu as fait ça aujourd'hui Lady
Justice regarde fixement un super prédateur
tu pensais que tu pouvais me terroriser moi et
les autres en silence tu avais tort nous sommes
ressuscités de tes cendres nous nous élevons ensemble
jour parce que Harvey Weinstein a
finalement été tenu responsable des crimes qu'il a
commis les femmes qui se sont manifestées
courageusement et que ce grand risque a rendu
cela possible
Weinstein est un prédateur sexuel en série vicieux
[Musique]
les femmes ont essayé d'en parler pendant
des décennies, elles ont essayé de parler  à
ce sujet et casser l'histoire juste qu'ils
ne pouvaient pas le faire, vous savez parce que tout le monde
avait peur, donc je pense que ce niveau de
pouvoir et de peur qu'il semble être capable
de lui générer que ce coup peut aller
[Musique]
à 21 ans, j'ai été violée par Harvey Weinstein, il
prétend que c'était consensuel, son avocat
affirme que Weinstein n'est pas à blâmer parce qu'il
n'a pas inventé le canapé de casting et
aussi parce que et c'est une citation directe
si une femme a des relations sexuelles pour aider sa
carrière à Hollywood qui  n'est pas un viol,
il était extrêmement persistant et
physiquement accablant,
il s'est ensuite imposé oralement à moi
pendant que j'avais mes règles, il a même
retiré mon tampon, j'étais mortifié,
j'étais incrédule et dégoûté, elle a
témoigné que m.  Weinstein a mis sa
main sur sa poitrine
et
qu'il a également tenté de toucher sa
zone vaginale qu'il s'est masturbée et
l'a éjaculée sur une serviette tombée sur le
sol
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand on pense à Weinstein, la raison pour laquelle
beaucoup ne l'ont pas fait  se manifester parce qu'il
détruirait cela et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous entendons maintes et maintes fois que nous sommes
des plaignants ne se sont pas manifestés, en
particulier dans ce cas spécifique,
parfois la raison pour laquelle les femmes ne se manifestent pas
et parfois les hommes gardent cela à
l'esprit est  Dommage
[Musique],
elle a dit que vous savez qu'elle était, vous
savez qu'elle a vécu la même chose que
tant d'autres femmes qui ont été
invitées dans sa chambre d'hôtel sous
prétexte d'une sorte de
réunion d'affaires à laquelle on lui a demandé de
lui donner un  massage vous savez en quelque sorte vous
connaissez la proposition de contact physique
et vous savez ce qui était remarquable, c'est qu'elle a
dit que vous savez qu'elle était jeune, elle avait
peur mais elle est allée dire à son petit ami
à l'époque qui se trouve être Brad Pitt
et il a confronté Harvey a dit  vous savez,
ne la touchez pas,
vous savez et et et Brad Pitt, vous savez
maintenant, a confirmé ce compte par l'intermédiaire d'un
représentant
[Musique]
pensez-vous qu'il est un symbole que vous connaissez de l'
oppression du pouvoir plus que tout ce que
nous avons tous connu, donc c'est un
visage collectif de l'homme des cauchemars
à droite la machine à complicité est celui que je
porte encore plus en jugement que lui
car il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas dans son
cerveau quelle est leur excuse mais il n'était pas
protégé juste par Hollywood Hollywood l'a
déifié il était leur chef de secte et
Je saurais que j'ai grandi dans un Je sais comment
ça se passe
[Musique]
Croyez-vous que toutes ces femmes
mentent Croyez-vous qu'elles mentent Commencez
merci beaucoup Avez-vous honte des
messages pour les femmes
[Applaudissements]
M.  Weinstein n'a pas inventé le canapé de casting
à Hollywood et dans la mesure
où il y a un mauvais comportement
dans cette industrie, ce n'est pas de cela qu'il s'agit,
le mauvais comportement n'est pas jugé dans
ce cas, c'est seulement si vous avez intentionnellement
commis un acte criminel et m.
Weinstein nie vigoureusement que
[Music]
aujourd'hui est vraiment un moment historique pour les
survivants de viols et d'agressions sexuelles dans la
mesure où le public voit que des hommes, même
un homme aussi puissant et célèbre que
Weinstein, seront tenus responsables de
leurs abus envers les femmes
[Music]
vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant, nous pouvons porter notre attention sur le
procès à venir ici à Los Angeles, nous avons l'
occasion de tirer parti de cet élan,
ce verdict n'est pas tout mais il est
significatif